monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale dans cinq jours débuteront les
épreuves comme une dévaluation continue
en classe de 1ère épreuve qui
s'inscrivent dans la réforme du
baccalauréat que vous avez souhaité
mettre en oeuvre alors c'est cette
première étape importante dans
l'évaluation globale des futurs
bacheliers de 2021 suscite chez les
lycéens une adresse bien légitime est
bien compréhensible mais cette nouvelle
formule génère et suscite aussi
l'inquiétude et surtout l'inquiétude des
professeurs et la panique parfois dans
les équipes chargées de l'organisation
au sein des établissements vous le savez
sans doute certains syndicats
enseignants appellent même au boycott de
ces épreuves par l'intermédiaire d'une
grève des de la survie en je ne
cautionne évidemment pas cette dérive
je considère que le sens des
responsabilité doit l'emporter mais
néanmoins cela révèle une rupture du
dialogue entre votre ministère et la
communauté éducative
il faut bien reconnaître l'impréparation
voir l' improvisation autour de ces
épreuves découverte tardive de la banque
de sujets la banque nationale de sujets
difficultés liées à la dématérialisation
des copies découverte aussi in extremis
du logiciel de correction bref les
griefs sont nombreux sans parler de du
régime indemnitaire pour les correcteurs
et plus d'une centaine d'actions sont en
cours à travers la france monsieur le
ministre
mesurez-vous l'ampleur et l'urgence à
cinq jours du début des épreuves de la
situation pouvez vous rassurer les
personnels et assuré que ces épreuves se
dérouleront dans des conditions normales
pour vous répondre